January certainly didn't have many games
released but what did come out served up
a healthy dose of fun whether we were
crossing swords in nidhogg laughing
through puzzles in broken age or
surviving the end of days in the banner
saga our gaming hours were spent playing
the initial batch of 2014 releases Oly
Oly triumphs over them all however and
paves the way for what should be another
excellent year there are two ways that
you can land while skateboarding if
you're skilled you land smoothly on your
wheels and glide on would like a
renegade angel if you're like us you
land headfirst bounce and then slam your
back into the concrete on the rebound as
you slowly turn into moaning hamburger
meat it's after the 12 consecutive
violent crash that you have to
re-evaluate your priorities are you
going to take up something less
dangerous like bullfighting or give one
last shot at immortality if you're
playing olly olly the answer is always
immortality upon first glance Oly Oly
looks remarkably simple and after you
sink hours into chasing high scores that
assessment won't change the beauty of
this portable wonder is in its
simplicity sure you won't have to tap
too many buttons or remember crazy moves
but if you're going to string together
an or inspiring combo you're going to
need exact timing and the humility to
recognize that you're not perfect
zipping through courses at top speed
grinding every rail spinning while
airborne landing treacherous jumps takes
sharp reflexes and firm concentrations
considering how often your face meets
the mint you need a short memory and a
lot of determination Oly Oly does a
great job of alleviating the pain so
long as you don't crash levels are over
in a blink and it only takes a second to
restart after a failed attempt varied
objects ensure you need to keep
employing different strategies and you
can fly through a course without pushing
off can you land every trick perfectly
easier said than done throw in a host of
different stage layouts and you're
always presented with a new challenge to
overcome olly olly NAB's our first game
of the month award because it's fast
exciting and all too happy to kick our
butt